my beef tonight is with the line trolls
at CNN MSNBC and the whole mainstream
media these legacy loons spent all day
ginning up fake controversies to try to
tear down President Trump and since he
is a rock with literally no physical
features or personality quirks worth
attacking the MSM has to go after his
staff his crew his insane clown posse
but joke's on you you rumour mongers
because Donald Trump only hires one kind
of people we're gonna get the best
people the best the best the best the
best the best the best I know the best
people the best people dev straight he
knows the best people and if you don't
know who they are well they're simply
the best
[Music]
came up with that all by myself first
the Robin to trump Superman is very own
son-in-law Jared Kushner six feet three
inches of pure alpha dog manpower the
world's gonna know your name what's your
name man my name is Jared Kushner I am
senior advisor to President Donald J
Trump whoa whoa is that Jared Kushner or
Barry White I'm pretty sure a thousand
puberty's just exploded across America
and what is this chiseled hunk of silly
putty been up to over it's 1,600 pen
guess what everything the president
tapping his son-in-law to reform the
criminal justice system not to mention
he's running the new office of American
innovation where he's responsible for
reforming veteran care tackling the
opioid epidemic and overseeing the not
so small feet of revamping the entire
federal government
he's also tasked with brokering peace in
the Middle East you know what I didn't
know better I'd almost think he was
trying to settle this guy with too many
responsibilities so he could steal his
wife but the country's most important
progress is about to stop in its tracks
because our boys access is getting shut
down Jared Kushner has been stripped of
his top-secret security clearance amid
questions about his foreign context and
business dealings officials from
multiple foreign countries have
discussed ways to manipulate Kushner by
taking advantage of his complex business
arrangements financial difficulties and
lack of foreign policy experience okay
whoa drop hired Jared for his lack of
experience he didn't want some stodgy
experience ridden bureaucrat that knows
how to properly pronounce Bosnia hers
ago
drop a lot of the cush a man that tied
down by know-how and untainted by
applicable skills
he's the diplomatic equivalent of veal
but now after all this media BS chief of
staff John Kelly has downgraded Jarrod's
top secret clearance to regular secret
clearance ah I mean he only gets the WAC
second-tier secrets like instead of
knowing what went down at area 51 in
Nevada he only gets to know what
happened at area 4 in Tampa spoiler
alert it's just a muskrat stuck at a
Devil Rays Jersey so now Jared doesn't
get those juicy secrets just because a
handful of countries like the United
Arab Emirates China Israel and Mexico
all thought it would be soup seesee to
take advantage of Kushner look the MSM
got this wrong Jarrod isn't vulnerable
just because his family reportedly
courted foreign investment from China
and Israel to other countries jared has
been in secret contact with coincidence
I think so yeah
because Jarrod doesn't need money he's
working for America out of the goodness
of his heart he works for nothing just
so you know nobody ever reports Steph
but he gets zero here oh yeah can't put
a price tag on that guy you could say
he's worthless which is why he's
[Music]
oh whoa people we could be here all day
because Trump's inner circle is like The
Godfather movies there all the best one
case in point
White House communications director Hope
Hicks who testified to Congress
yesterday about Trump's so-called ties
to Russia hope Hicks told house
investigators on Tuesday that her work
for president Trump who has a reputation
for exaggerations and outright
falsehoods had occasionally required her
to tell white lies
no big deal just white lies ivory fibs
eggshell Jews hope Hicks never told
outright lies that would be disgraceful
no hope Hicks just told white lies which
seems somehow more what's the word not
guilty in fact she ever ends up having
to commit white perjury in front of a
probably white judge and gets convicted
of a white crime she could rest easy
because if there's one thing I know
about white crime it's that you never go
to jail for it the worst that could
happen is you resigned to bigger and
better things which is what happened
hours ago
breaking news White House communications
director hope Hicks is resigning that's
right she was such the best people she's
already been promoted all the way out of
the White House
hope Hicks you're
[Music]
yeah love that trumpet moving on to the
final Trump best or not a real American
the prestigious high quality supportive
civil servant that this country needs
dr. Ben Carson's chair and it's not just
any chair
listen taxpayer outrage over the budget
for decorating HUD secretary Ben
Carson's office the $31,000 dining set
and the staffer who claims she was told
five thousand dollars won't even buy a
decent chair five thousand dollars can't
even buy a decent chair and you need
that decent chair as opposed to an
indecent chair which is what Mike Pence
calls any piece of furniture that's been
sat on by a woman Ben Carson's at least
five thousand dollar chair is a hero
it's stable reliable swivels and
supports the Department of Housing and
Urban Development Secretary ben Carson
who is basically in charge of making
sure Americans have roofs over their
heads and food in their tummies so he
needs a good chair I mean look at that
chair you could eat off that chair just
imagine how many people could eat from
that chair because it's so there you
have it
Trump only hires the best people and his
cabinet is magnificent but not as
magnificent as Ben Carson's which is
solid mahogany and cost 1.8 million
dollars
[Music]